Moneyball was written by Aaron Sorkin
which stars Brad Pitt is a frequent
collaborator with David Fincher on films
such as 7th Fight Club Mercury's Case of
Benjamin Button
David Fincher also directed the social
network which was written by Aaron
Sorkin and eventually they're all
connected to Kevin Bacon in some way
there are rich teams and there are poor
teams then there's 50 feet of crap and
then there's us that's a dollar then
what welcome to Oakland Moneyball stars
Brad Pitt Jonah Hill Philip Seymour
Hoffman and some other people who are
talented as well it's the true story of
the general manager of the Oakland
Athletics back in the early 2000s he
tried to build a baseball team based off
of statistics based off of numbers who
fields this who can give the most RBIs
who gets on base the most who has the
best hit percentage and it wasn't
looking at players based off their pure
raw talent of being able to play he
tried to build a good team based off of
the statistics and Jonah Hill is the
character who helped him do that and
they work together to try to build a
team that a lot of people didn't think
would win because it was an idea that
was never really thought of our use
before I need more money
we're not New York fine players or the
money that we do have I like Perez not
an ugly girlfriend ugly girlfriend means
no confidence you guys are talking the
same old nonsense like we're looking for
Fabio we got to think differently there
are two different ways I could have
taken this movie they could have taken
the very serious route and showed it to
be just a really serious event very
dramatic with a little bit of humor
thrown in there you know this film has
just the right amount of both in my
opinion Steven Zaillian and Aaron Sorkin
are the writers of this film and as we
know Aaron Sorkin wrote the social
network and so this film is a very good
scripting incredibly clever and witty
read pit and Jonah Hill believe it or
not have excellent chemistry with one
another and you wouldn't think of
putting them together in a movie but
they work really well together and I
especially like Brad Pitt's performance
he's really honestly one of my favorite
actors he's all those actors where
people give him that
he's like this incredibly hot celebrity
and everything but the roles he takes
and the ways in which he goes about
playing his characters he doesn't act
like that I mean he plays a lot of
really excellent characters he always
chooses really good scripts and I
honestly can't think of a movie that
he's been in that I haven't liked for a
long time your goal shouldn't be to bite
players your goal should be to buy wings
in order to buy wings you need to buy
runs who are you
I'm Peter brand first job in baseball
it's my first job anywhere and this is
one of the last movies were gonna get
where Jonah Hill is still fat this and
the sitter coming out later this year
because apparently he's like stick
skinny now but I liked him in this movie
I thought he was good too
the director Bennett Miller is the
director of the film Capote which also
starred Philip Seymour Hoffman I haven't
seen that film Hoffman doesn't have that
much to do in this movie I thought the
director made a really good-looking film
a really good-looking film and I'll say
that I'll talk a little bit more about
the direction later also Brad Pitt has a
really really sweet relationship with
his young daughter I love that
relationship it was like the heart of
the movie like there was a whole bunch
of conflict what he was trying to do
with the baseball but all the scenes he
had with his daughter were just so sweet
and really well portrayed in their minds
is threatening a game he's running away
that they do things hey daddy you think
you lose your job what
where'd you hear that well I go on the
internet sometimes don't go on the
internet watch TV talk to people the
problem with the movie though for me is
that it is way too long the film is over
two hours and for a very wordy film like
this it is witty and fun and clever
there's a lot of scenes I think that
could have been cut I think about 20
minutes of this movie could have been
cut so it would have flowed better had
better pacing but for the most part I
really enjoyed Moneyball I just feel
that it got way too long and that it
should have been cut a bit and it made a
little bit boring and it screw up the
pacing which is one of the problems I
had with the director because the
director made the movie look excellent
there was just some problems that I had
with the pacing of the film that made it
way down and not be something great for
me also the script has a couple scenes
in this movie that are just fantastic
there are a few scenes in this movie
that stand out particularly one in which
it shows Brad Pitt and Jonah Hill trying
to successfully make an incredibly
last-minute trade where they're on the
phone
talking with each other at the same time
trying to make the trade talking to the
secretary it was hilarious it was such a
well done scene you're discounting what
scouts have done for a hundred and fifty
years what am i doing
what is happening in Oakland it defies
everything we know about baseball
crazy I really enjoyed Moneyball I do
love baseball movies and that will also
help me to like it but at the same time
I think if you don't like baseball
you'll still enjoy this film I think it
has a lot to enjoy besides just people
who like baseball I do I love baseball
movies the Sam Pot natural field of
dreams a lot of good movies that I've
seen that our baseball films but I'm
going to give Moneyball a B+ if we win
this team will change the game
this better work I'm just kidding
but if you liked my review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck my